[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the standard model
the standard model brings together all
the elementary particles
which make up the universe in one single
theory
elementary particles are fundamental
elements at the base of the entire
universe
they are the smallest particles they
cannot be broken down
or divided the standard model sorts out
these elementary particles
in different groups firstly
the universe is made up of matter mata
is fundamental to living beings
planets stars and everything that has a
mass
the elementary particles which make up
mata are named fermions
there are two main categories of
fermions quarks
and leptons the quarks and leptons that
make up all matter
exist under three different forms which
we call generations
to each generation is associated a pair
of quarks and a pair of leptons
the first generation is made up of up
and down quarks
along with two types of leptons
electrons and electron neutrinos
these are the most common particles
found in our universe
when they bind together in groups of
three up and down quarks form the
protons and the neutrons
which are the essential components of
the atomic nucleus
electrons are also present in atoms
orbiting the protons and neutrons
their negative charge cancels out the
positive charge of protons
so that matter can remain neutral
by travelling in electric wires
electrons are also responsible for
electricity
finally electron neutrinos are the
matter particles most numerous in the
universe
over 1 000 billion go through our body
each second they have the property that
they do not interact with mata
which makes them very difficult to
detect
the second generation of mata is made up
of charm and strange quarks
along with muons and muon neutrinos
these four particles have a mass that is
greater than those of the first
generation
finally the third generation is made up
of top and bottom quarks
along with tau and tau neutrinos
these four particles are more massive
yet compared to the two first
generations
the particles of the second and third
generation are very rare in the universe
which is almost entirely made up of
first generation particles
[Music]
following on all matter particles exist
in either of two versions
indeed there is another form of mata
which we call
anti-matter which associates that each
particle an
anti-particle anti-particles have the
same characteristics as normal particles
but their electric charge is opposite
[Music]
finally there are particles which are
not constitutive to matter
which we call bosons a boson
is a particle which will act like a
messenger to enable the interaction at a
distance
between two mata particles four of these
are named gauge bosons these gauge
bosons each represent a force
in the universe the photon is the gauge
boson associated to electromagnetic
interaction
it moves about at the speed of light and
gives rise to magnetism
as well as the light itself the gluon is
the gauge boson associated with strong
interaction
this force plays out at a microscopic
scale and is very powerful
it maintains quarks together which
themselves form protons and neutrons
finally z0 w plus and w minus bosons
are the gauge bosons associated with
weak interaction
this force underlies phenomena like the
radioactivity of particles
or the nuclear fusion which takes place
within stars like the sun
there exists in the standard model one
last boson
the higgs boson the higgs boson does not
really represent a force
but a field this higgs field
gives a mass to the particles that go
through it
the more particles interact with this
field the greater their mass
there exist in the universe a great
diversity of elementary particles
which the standard model combines all
together in a single theory
however this theory cannot explain
everything
for example the standard model does not
yet include gravity which is essential
to the universe
for this physicists have suggested the
existence of a boson
which would carry gravitational
interaction the graviton
however its existence remains only a
hypothesis
[Music]
[Music]
you